herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
seit putins rede vor ungefähr 24 stunden
ist die welt eine andere hat die spirale
in russland ukraine konflikt ein anderes
level erreicht es rollen panzer putin
macht ernst und es war dieser satz der
den startschuss gegeben hat
in diesem zusammenhang halte ich es für
nötig eine längst reif gewordene
entscheidung zu treffen
unverzüglich die souveränität und
unabhängigkeit der volksrepublik dann
jetzt und der volksrepublik lohans kann
zu erkennen
und von denjenigen die die macht in kiew
verlangen wir sofort die kampfhandlungen
einzustellen
andernfalls wird die verantwortung für
weiteres blutvergiessen ganz und gar bei
dem ukrainischen regime liegt
putin erkennt die selbstständigkeit der
selbsternannten
volksrepublik dann jetzt und lohans
anbricht damit das minsker abkommen
sendet soldaten und panzer
friedenstruppen die er sie nennt nach
den jetzt und lohans was bedeutet das
ganze eine kriegserklärung ist das sagt
heute der ukrainische botschafter in
berlin was bedeutet das ganze was droht
jetzt was lässt sich aus putins rede
analysieren das wollen wir gemeinsam
besprechen mit dem general egon ramms
grüße sie ganz herzlich schuhen von 2007
bis 2010 oberbefehlshaber der airline
joint force command und damit einer der
ranghöchsten deutschen soldaten in der
nato was haben sie sie haben gestern die
rede von putin verfolgt was haben sie
was ist ihnen da durch den kopf gegangen
aber so formuliert dass mal etwas anders
ich habe die gesamte wohl vorbereitete
inszenierung des gestrigen tages
verfolgt die ja in mehreren schritten im
halbstunden stundenrhythmus sich
fortgesetzt hat einmal über diesen
nationalen sicherheitsrat der im jahr
diese anerkennung empfohlen hat sondern
über seine lange rede die er gehalten
hat ich sage das mit meinen worten das
was er vorhat zu rechtfertigen wohlan
mit dem satz was geändert hat den sie
gerade berichtet haben anschließend
diese schöne zeremonie wo er mit den
beiden separatisten führen die dokumente
unterzeichnet hat für die anerkennung
und dann begann eigentlich bei mir so
die erste frage was heißt das eigentlich
was er gemacht hat reden wir über das
gebiet welches in der hand der
separatisten ist oder reden wir über die
beiden ob laste noch hans grundt und
soll jetzt als ganzes die ja ich sag mal
mit einem etwa ein großer vergleich zu
zwei dritteln noch in der hand der
ukrainischen
sokratischen regimes lokalen regierung
ist und der dort befindlichen
streitkräfte der regime begriff gerade
war falsch ich möchte mich in den
sprachgebrauch von der putin bewegen
weil das eine ordnungsgemäße
demokratisch gewählte regierung ist die
sich dort befindet und die sollte man
schon sprechen können wir gehen gleich
ausführlich darauf noch ein also es
entstehen viele fragen und wenn sie
fragen haben dann einfach her über e
mail facebook oder youtube wir werden
das alles dann gemeinsam besprechen
dieser hat putins rede hat die welt
verändert seit gestern die anerkennung
der selbsternannten volksrepublik
johanns und dann jetzt hat auch heute
direkte folgen gezeigt erst mal hat die
russische duma den militäreinsatz den
putin die regierung angefragt hat
gebilligt und es scheint als stünden
eventuell schon panzer auf
ostukrainischen gebiet was heute alles
genau geschah was geschehen ist fast
unser korrespondent aus moskau
kristiansand zusammen diese bilder
sollen russisches militär zeigen dass
sich bereits in don jetzt befindet das
behaupten auch die separatisten
verifizieren lässt sich das nicht
seit gestern nacht feiern sie in bonn
jetzt die anerkennung ihrer
unabhängigkeit
russland hurra der dank geht nach moskau
für uns ist das sehr wichtig wir wollen
als eine große familie zusammen mit
russland leben ich weiß nicht wie gut
die entscheidung ist und ob sie uns zum
frieden führt
wladimir putin hat gestern fakten
geschaffen mit dem dekret erkennt
russland die unabhängigkeit der
separatisten gebiete an heute folgte die
bestätigung durch das russische
parlament die anerkennung der
unabhängigkeit ist auch ein bruch der
minsker friedensvereinbarungen für die
ost ukraine von 2015 heute legt putin
noch mal nach und gibt der ukraine die
schuld
dass münster abkommen war schon tot
lange vor der gestrigen anerkennung der
volksrepublik 'nimm donners nicht durch
unsere schuld oder die der
repräsentanten dieser republik sondern
durch die handlungsweise der jetzigen
staatsmacht in kiew
im süden russlands im gebiet roßdorf
gibt es truppenbewegungen in richtung
separatisten gebiete russland hat mit
der anerkennung gestern auch
militärische unterstützung zugesagt
offiziell aber ist der befehl noch nicht
erfolgt das könnte putin aber jederzeit
tun
sagen haben sie haben es eben auch schon
gesagt das wirkte gestern für sie ein
bisschen orchestriert es gab mal
eilmeldung ukrainisches gepanzertes
fahrzeug auf russischem gebiet fünf
ukrainische soldaten getötet die ukraine
kiew hat das dementiert
grenzposten seien beschossen worden
glaubhaft dass alles was schon gestern
begonnen hat als vorbereitung vor dieser
rede oder ist das sozusagen alles
wirklich inszenierung orchestriert also
ich würde sie nicht ich wüsste nicht wo
chronische soldaten oder ukrainische
gepanzerte fahrzeuge
in diesem bereich das heißt also dann
ostwärts der der beiden unabhängigen
republiken an die russische grenze
kommen sollten und wie sie dahin
gekommen sein könnten von daher sage ich
mal das ist eine saubere desinformation
von der ja auch in den letzten wochen
und monaten gegenüber der ukrainischen
bevölkerung aber auch gegenüber der
bevölkerung im westen von russischer
seite sehr viel gebrauch gemacht worden
ist und das gehört mittlerweile zum
normalen programm man kann sich darüber
streiten ob der hybride krieg bereits in
allen aspekten begonnen hat oder aber
erst noch anfangen muss ich darf mir
eine bemerkung erlauben ich habe heute
einmal von reuters und einmal von einer
idealen italienische agentur gehört dass
man die ersten panzer in der ost ukraine
also in den partisanen oder separatisten
gebieten entsprechend gesehen hat von
daher gehe ich mal aus dass der
angriffsbefehl gäste haben tatsächlich
erteilt worden ist sie weiter eine
filigrane neben speziellen bilder die
man nicht so ganz verifizieren kann das
aber aber auf frühjahr und die
italienische agentur verlasse ich mich
normalerweise ganz gerne das heißt
zumindest dass der ein oder andere
gefechts verband hat die grenze
überschritten wobei das ja im augenblick
noch nicht so bedeutungsvoll ist sondern
wichtig wird es dann wenn es an diese
trennlinie die wir für schusslinie geht
dann wird es interessant dann wollen wir
uns als einfach mal vielleicht genauer
angucken auch mit einer karte wollen wir
einen blick werfen eben auf die lage die
ukraine nach dem sturz des pro
russischen ukrainischen präsidenten
janukowitsch im jahr 2014 da annektierte
russland die krim und gleichzeitig gab
es eben kämpfe haben pro-russische
separatisten in den regionen lohans und
dann jetzt kämpfe begonnen nach ansicht
des westens hat moskau eben von anfang
an diese separatisten dort unterstützt
was bedeutet das jetzt wenn putin
hingeht und sagt er erkennt die
unabhängigkeit der gesamten
selbsternannten volksrepublik ihn an und
nicht etwa von separatisten gebieten
aber ich darf noch zwei bemerkungen
vorher schieben die eine bemerkung ist
die geschichte wiederholt sich nicht
trotzdem ist die kollektion der krim
genau einen tag nach dem ende der
olympischen winterspiele in sotchi
erfolgt oder hat begonnen geschichte
wiederholt sich nicht die entscheidungen
zu die wir gestern gesehen haben die im
fernsehen so demonstrativ gezeigt worden
sind
erfolgt jetzt ebenfalls einen tag nach
dem winter spiegel das scheint ihnen
sehr markantes datum zu sein so ein
bisschen ironisch dabei vielleicht
gemeint aber trotzdem dass der eine
punkt aber und der zweite punkt der
nicht anmerken möchte ist einfach der
dass ich sage die situation die sich
dort entwickelt hat auch mit den
separatisten gebieten sie sehen an der
karte für die zuschauer dass etwa ein
drittel unter der kontrolle der
separatisten ist und die anderen zwei
sind unter kontrolle also die regierung
und die regionalen hauptstädte lohans
daniel das gehören dazu aber sozusagen
der größere teil des geländes ist
praktisch nach wie vor unter organischer
kontrolle und dort befinden sich auch so
komische streitkräfte und ich bitte
einfach unsere zuschauer mal auf diese
linie zu gucken die sich da zwischen dem
ich sag mal braun gelb und rot
gesperrten bereich durchzieht wenn die
russischen streitkräfte diese linie
erreicht haben dann ist die stelle
gekommen wo es interessant wird mich mit
der frage gehen sie weiter oder gehen
sie nicht weiter wenn sie weitergehen
müssen wir in jedem falle von krieg
reden wobei die frage die heute auch zum
teil diskutiert worden ist ist es schon
eine invasion oder ist es keine die ist
für mich eindeutig beantwortet
überschreiten russischer kräfte von der
internationalen grenze der ukraine
das ist ja völkerrechtlich immer noch
ukrainischer bereich ist diese invasion
erfolgt das heißt alle konsequenzen die
im eu nato oder sonst irgendwo
angekündigt worden sind müssten jetzt
eigentlich erfolgen sie haben es jetzt
gerade gesagt es ist offen und die frage
wird sich sehr bald stellen wenn
russische truppen die ja wohl
offensichtlich vielleicht schon in
diesem gebiet sind aber eben diese linie
erreichen diese
diese grenze linie wo eben auf der einen
seite dann die ukrainischen soldaten
sind wie weit eskaliert dass ganze
hätten den ukrainische truppen die
ukrainischen soldaten die eben noch auf
diesem gebiet sind überhaupt irgendeine
chance also sie haben folgen gesprochen
von den rund 150 tausend soldaten die
die russen dort zusammengezogen haben
nach meiner auffassung sind es
mittlerweile
wenn ich die übungen in weißrussland
belarus mit betrachte wahrscheinlich
sogar eine zahl von 190.000 das heißt
das steigert sich im augenblick noch die
ukrainische streitkräfte haben etwa eine
stärke von 200.000 mann die ukrainische
armee war 2014 an reaktionen der krim
und beginnen dieser gefechtshandlungen
in der ost ukraine ich sag das mal
völlig abgewirtschaftet und
die ukrainische armee ist in den letzten
acht jahren nicht aufgerüstet worden das
wäre falsch aber sie ist in teilen
modernisiert worden und die
waffensysteme sind wieder einsatzfähig
sind auch zum teil mit blick auf
kommunikationssysteme und dergleichen
verbessert worden und gesteckt noch ein
weiterer wesentlicher punkt dahinter der
mir sehr wichtig ist die ukrainische
soldaten zeigen kampfwillen das heißt
sie wollen ihr vaterland verteidigen und
das ist ihre einstellung und das ist
wird sicherlich ich sage mal keinen
durchmarsch für die schützen sollen
insofern wird es jetzt eben spannend
wenn man jetzt fragt wie weit eskaliert
dass ganze was will putin es ist ja eben
genau die schwierige frage was will er
wie weit will er gehen sie haben es
angesprochen
es stehen ja russische truppen nicht nur
hier im osten der ukraine im nordosten
sondern eben auch in belarus auf der
krim sind russische truppen deutet das
denn an diese nennen wir es umzingelung
dass putin mehr will als nur den don was
am ende unter kontrolle bringen also ich
möchte darüber eigentlich gibt es noch
nicht spekulieren aber die möglichkeiten
und die option auch von anderer seite
her also nicht aus dem osten sondern
beispielsweise auch aus dem norden mit
unterstützung von belarus oder auch aus
dem süden über die krim
die ukraine anzugreifen hat er darüber
gibt es keine frage das würde auch die
situation was die kräfteverhältnisse
angeht für die ukraine deutlich
verschlechtern weil sie praktisch an
mehreren stellen gleichzeitig anfangen
müsste zu kämpfen und sich dann
möglicherweise aufteilen müsste was zur
fortsetzung führen kann
vielleicht noch eine anmerkung die ganze
entwicklung die dort ist es auch mit
blick auf völkerrecht und dergleichen
mehr eine schreckliche entwicklung sie
ist hochinteressant aber wir müssen das
ganze auch mit dem ich sage mal mit
einer bestimmten sprachlichen
disziplinen entsprechend handhaben es
handelt sich wenn das tatsächlich so
passiert um einen krieg der
menschenleben kosten wird und das sollte
im bewusstsein verankert worden das ist
eben die frage sie haben es ja schon
deutlich gemacht die ukraine
verteidigen eben dann ihre heimat ihr
vaterland
das ist dann eben auch die frage wie
weit kann putin gehen ja wie viel blut
soll kann er eigentlich auch in kauf
nehmen
sozusagen zuhause also da gibt es ist
eine sehr interessante und sehr gute
frage weil wir haben schon fälle erlebt
wo russische truppen an anderer stelle
eingesetzt gewesen sind tschetschenien
georgien und dergleichen mehr muss ich
dann irgendwann die russischen mutter
ich sage das absichtlich so zu wort
gemeldet haben das heißt also wenn die
ersten russischen soldaten väter söhne
kinder nach hause kommen wird es in
russland reaktionen geben und dann erst
wird sich zeigen wie weit die russische
bevölkerung selber diese anerkennung
dieser beiden bereiche und die damit
verbundenen kriegshandlung entsprechend
akzeptiert oder unterstützt ich glaube
nicht so sehr eine unterstützung dabei
weil sich bei vorangegangenen
auseinandersetzung auch bereits gezeigt
hat dass dann irgendwann widerstand
kommt und dieser widerstand
wird dann laufe der zeit immer größer
das seite bringen diese operation sehr
schnell zu ende was ich nicht glaube
sorgen machen sich alle christoph späth
schreibt über facebook fragt sie heran
falls es zu einer internationalen
eskalation kommt ist es realistisch in
einem konventionellen konflikt die
russischen truppen vor der deutschen
grenze aufzuhalten schreibt er und muss
es um eine eskalation wieder ein neues
muss es um eine eskalation wieder ein
neues aufrüsten von europa geben also es
sind schon gedanken die sehr viel weiter
gehen also nicht der ukraine erste
anmerkung zu dieser frage diese guten
frage muss ich sagen also ich glaube
nicht dass es besonder die deutsche
grenze gehen wird weil ich das so sehe
dass die grenzlinie die zur nato führt
also angefangen bei estland unten bis
runter nach rumänien und bulgarien
eine grenze ist wo putin wenn er die
überschreiten würde in eine völlig
andere qualität rein käme ich weise
darauf hin dass die nato um dieses dort
nicht zu machen
einmal die vorwärts stationierten
millione in estland lettland litauen
polen hat und ich weise darauf hin dass
die nato einen teil dieser bataillone
oder battle groups wie sie genannt
werden aber auch andere bereiche auch
auf bilateraler basis die amerikaner
beispielsweise in rumänien und den polen
bereits verstärkungen dorthin gebracht
haben um auf diese art und weise putin
ich sag das mal mit meinen worten von
einem grenzübertritt in nato-vertrags
gebiet abzuhalten das ist die bewertung
und die beurteilen die ich mache das
problem ist wir wissen dass die ukraine
nicht zur nato gehört dass die nato kann
auch gegenüber der ukraine außer
unterstützungsleistung im bereich
ausbildung oder auf bilateraler basis
von waffen und munitionslieferungen dort
entsprechend keine unterstützung leisten
dass es möglicherweise heute als
bedauerlich anzusehen ich beurteile die
situation aber etwas anders als unser
bundeskanzler letzte woche getan hat er
sich ja mit herrn putin
ich sag das mal vor sich etwas flapsig
darüber portal wer von den beiden länger
im hand bleibt dass das bald nicht mehr
erleben werden damit ist in meinen augen
falsches zeichen gesetzt worden man
sollte diese möglichkeit dass die
ukraine mitglied wird durchaus
aufenthalten aber unter den
entsprechenden bedingungen die in allem
entsprechen aufnahme planen dann
festzulegen und foto zu sehen sind so
ist das beim alten bei polen bei rumänen
und bulgaren auch erfolgt und wir
sollten da keine ausnahme machen mit
blick auf die ukraine aber dieses
gänzlich ausschließen ist das auslassen
einer option die möglicherweise in
diesem ganzen konzert oder in diesen
ganzen konzertierten aktion durchaus
eine rolle spielen können
unser user die mode 13 oder hat ihn
schreibt sie wie youtube will putin sich
die gesamte ukraine einverleiben wir
kommen also damit noch mal auf die frau
zurück geht es nur um den don was sind
die truppen aufmärsche ein indiz dafür
dass es um die ganze ukraine geht bevor
wir darüber reden schauen wir uns mal
noch einen weiteren ausschnitt aus
putins rede von gestern an ob sie
vielleicht auch ein weiteren hinweis
geht
verstehen die ukraine dann nicht dass
sie nicht nur ein protektorat sind
sondern marionetten die privatisierung
des staates hat zum verlust von
souveränität geführt und dazu dass die
regierung keinen nationalen charakter
mehr hat
putin spricht hier nicht etwa die ost
ukraine an oder russen es gibt ja viele
jetzt die einen russischen pass haben in
den von den separatisten besetzten
gebieten nein er spricht die ukraine an
und sagt sagt ihr seid doch quasi nur
marionetten spielt damit auf den westen
an ist das ein hinweis dass er da
sozusagen dann gesamt die ukraine im
visier hat also ich möchte dazu zwei
anmerkungen noch um die eine anmerkung
ist ich kann das nicht ausschließen aber
ich weiß es nicht ich kann das heute
nicht beurteilen was er tatsächlich
vorhat so wie er sicher in den letzten
tagen und wochen sollte mitte dezember
in dieser frage mit dem was gestern
passiert ist hat auch nicht in die
karten gucken lassen und ich glaube ich
spreche auch für viele politiker oder
andere experten wir sind gestern alle
überrascht worden das muss man in aller
deutlichkeit festhalten und dieser
überraschungsmoment kann auch an anderer
stelle möglicherweise wirkung zeigen die
zweite anmerkung die ich habe ist diese
art und weise wie er die ukraine hier
kennzeichnet so nach dem motto
marionetten start und sonstige dinge
mehr seine sache die finde ich nicht gut
und immer wieder spricht sich in seiner
eigenen rede auch weil er etwas
ähnliches sagt zu den baltischen staaten
beispielsweise hier früher mal
sowjetrepubliken waren genauso wie die
ukraine und weil das möglicherweise den
hinweis geben könnte dass er mit diesem
kleineren staaten eigentlich noch viel
nachlässiger und herabwürdigender umgeht
also dass der westen mit der ukraine
jemals getan hat
jetzt kommt kommen wir auf den westen
einfach mal man muss sich ja heute
fragen oder wir haben es alle irgendwie
beobachtet das ganze telefonieren
konferieren drohen gut zureden die hand
reichen hat ja offensichtlich nicht viel
gebracht oder hat putin nicht davon
abgehalten das zu tun was er eben machen
will seinem skript was er sozusagen nur
in seinem kopf hat
zufolge ist das so eine art
erfolgloses api smend wie in den 30er
jahren dass wir jetzt hier sehen
also ich hoffe dass nicht ich hoffe dass
die hippies und politik der
dreißigerjahre sich jetzt nicht in den
20er jahren des nächsten jahrhunderts
wiederholt ich sag das mal so mit diesen
worten weil das wäre eine schreckliche
situation aber wir müssen den gesamten
zeit komplex betrachten und dieser zeit
komplett beginnt für mich mit der
berühmten rede putins im deutschen
bundestag im jahr 2001 er setzt sich
fort über den georgien krieg setzt sich
fort über die annexion der krim um die
jetzige situation die praktisch seit
gestern in dieser form begonnen hat und
da scheint schon irgendwo einen fahrplan
hinter zu stehen und da muss man sich
die frage stellen ja möglicherweise das
rote signal setzt damit dieser fahrplan
nicht ständig weiter ausgeführt wird wir
können das vielleicht eine karte auch
noch mal dazu anschauen weil sie ja
sagen lassen sie uns auch mal
zurückblicken es gibt ja nicht nur den
konflikt ukraine sondern wir könnten
vielleicht die karte uns einfach mal
anschauen wo deutlich wird was es eben
schon gegeben hat im februar 2000 nimmt
die russische armee die
tschetschenischen hauptstadt grosny ein
ja also tschetschenien anfangs noch ja
sehr widerstandfähig oder widerspenstig
hat sogar zum rückzug geführt aber unter
putin eben unter putin ist es gewesen
ist am ende tschetschenien grosny
gefallen 2008 schlägt die russland die
russische armee die georgische armee in
nur fünf tagen kann man natürlich auch
mal fragen ist das zu vergleichen mit
der ukraine aber nur fünf tage haben
ausgereicht um die familie um diese
armee zu schlagen da geht es erklären
sie es in georgien um zwei ebenfalls
abtrünnige regionen die eben putin auch
als selbstständige
sozusagen republik in anerkannte 2018
georgienkrieg möchte ich zwei
anmerkungen machen die eine anmerkung
ist die dass die ersten über
geheimdienstliche kanäle erfahren haben
dass die 58 der armee das 58 armeekorps
nördlich von von südossetien im prinzip
nach einer übung in den übungsräumen
verblieben war kommt mir irgendwie
bekannt vor erleben wir jetzt auch oder
haben wir jetzt ist heute erlebt und die
sind dann nach dem georgien krieg
angefangen hat das muss man fairerweise
feststellen und ehrlicherweise
verstellen sind dann schnellstens nach
südossetien eingestiegen und haben die
georgischen streitkräfte
geschlagen zweite anmerkung in
verbindung mit dem georgien krieg gab es
kritik gegeben an russland und das
verhalten damals war mit betis präsident
in russland und mit tiffert damals
öffentlich gesagt
russland hat das recht jeden russisch
sprechenden bürger auf dem territorium
anderer staaten zu schützen
das sind man die mit betreff doktrin das
ist eine sache die ist von westen her
nie widersprochen worden er hätte mal
aufschreiben müssen weil das
völkerrechtswidrig ist wie eine art und
weise die schlimmer kaum sein kann das
hat man nicht getan und dann kommen die
russen irgendwann und sagen na ja da hat
man ja nicht darauf reagiert dann machen
wir das halt eben 50 in ähnlicher form
und damit sind wir dann möglicherweise
auch wieder in der ukraine war den osten
der ukraine moldau dort hat sich
transnistrien abgespalten in lettland
und in litauen hat es bei der befreiung
der dieser beiden völker in den
neunzigern und 90er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts tote gegeben es gibt den
sogenannten blutsonntag von vilnius im
januar 1991 das sind alles dinge die
haben wir nicht mehr auf dem schirm oder
sind verdrängt worden und dies ist alles
aus der zeit wo punkt in der nacht das
muss man mal einfach zusammenzählen um
auf diese art und weise zu einem urteil
zu kommen was vielleicht ein bisschen
realistischer ist als über die dinge zu
reden nach dem motto wir müssen mit
russland zusammenarbeiten und so weiter
und so weiter also der blick zurück und
die vielen mosaiksteinchen mal zusammen
tun was sie jetzt gerade gemacht haben
hilft um eben die frage vielleicht zu
beantworten wie tickt putin nicht nur
die rede gestern zu sehen nun hat nicht
nur die eu heute über sanktionen
gesprochen klar sondern vor wenigen
minuten bis jetzt eigentlich spricht
immer noch us-präsident beiden und die
welt hat auch da gespannt hingeschaut
wie denn jetzt der westen wie denn jetzt
beiden der us-präsident reagiert was er
ankündigen wird uns da können wir jetzt
schalten zu unserem korrespondenten
elmar theveßen in washington spricht
beiden noch was hat er bisher gesagt was
können wir aus washington hören
ja sein statement ist beendet der rat
auch sich den fragen nicht gestellt
hinterher aber er hat eine frage
beantwortet die ja vorhin von einem user
gestellt worden ist wird putin noch
weiter gehen der us präsident ist der
festen überzeugung ja er hofft dass er
dabei fall schlägt aber er glaubt dass
dieser wie erinnerte bizarre auftritt
von wladimir putin gestern tatsächlich
das rational geschaffen hat um eben dann
weiter zu gehen um andere teile der
ukraine zu erobern das was wir heute
gehört haben das ist also um die
gesamten autonomen gebiete nicht nur
geht luhansk und donnert sondern weit
darüber hinaus den don was zu besetzen
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit das deutet
darauf hin us präsident biden hat sehr
klare und harte sanktionen angekündigt
aber gleich dazu gesagt das werde in
wellen kommen man will also sich auch
noch einige sanktionen übrig lassen um
auf weitere aktivitäten der russen zu
reagieren und das was er angekündigt hat
gebe ich mal wieder hier zum einen hat
er gesagt dass es eine sanktion oder
sanktionen geben wird gegen zwei sehr
große banken in russland das ist die vtb
und das ist die militär bank in russland
die spielen eine wichtige rolle weil
über sie eben auch gehälter und eben
auch renten auch gerade im militärischen
bereich ausgegeben werden diese banken
kommen auf die sanktionsliste dazu hat
er angekündigt dass russland verboten
werden soll
schulden zu machen in europa aber auch
in den usa das heißt kann keine kredite
mehr aufnehmen auch das soll die
russische wirtschaft hart treffen
darüber hinaus wird es auch sanktionen
gegen ihn bieten und ihre familien so
hat der präsident das formuliert geben
das bedeutet sie werden auf eine liste
gesetzt die nennt sich specialized
nationals diese liste dient dazu dass
diese personen keine geschäfte mehr
machen können dass alle ihre guthaben
eingefroren werden zum beispiel bei
banken in europa und in den usa
darüber hinaus hat er noch einmal
begrüßt dass deutschland sich
entschieden hat die nord stream zwei
plan auf eis zu legen und er hat auch
klar gesagt diese pipeline wird niemals
in betrieb gehen wenn wladimir putin
nicht dass zurückzieht was er gestern
getan hat der präsident kündigte auch
weitere sanktionen an für den fall dass
tatsächlich eben es angriffe auf andere
bereiche der ukraine gibt möglicherweise
auch auf die hauptstadt kiew er schickt
zusätzliche soldaten ins baltikum das
ist ihm besonders wichtig weil der
premier putin klar machen will dass wenn
auch nur ein inch von nato territorium
in irgendeiner weise betroffen ist dann
werde die nato natürlich auch die
mitgliedstaaten verteidigen und er sagt
aber gleichzeitig dazu das sind
ausschließlich verteidigungsmaßnahmen
die die usa und die nato da ergreifen
man habe keinerlei absicht in einen
kampf mit russland sich hineinziehen zu
lassen und er hofft weiterhin dass es
noch chancen gibt auf diplomatie obwohl
das hat glaube ich der präsident sehr
klar gemacht er anhand dieser rede von
gestern das gefühl hat dass wladimir
putin weiter vorrücken wird und damit
auch eine weitere eskalation zu erwarten
ist
wir erinnern uns allerdings auch daran
dass vor gar nicht allzu langer zeit
beiden einer rede gegeben hat in der ära
putin gewarnt hat bei einem einmarsch in
die ukraine dürfte putin bloß kein
us-bürger ein haar krümmen er werde aber
bei einer invasion eben keine
amerikanischen truppen in die ukraine
schicken war das nicht irgendwie eine
art freifahrtschein daneben für putin
und wird sich putin von diesen
sanktionen von denen ja jetzt beiden
spricht und auch diese welle
beeindrucken lassen wird das irgendwie
putin davon abhalten eben diesen
freifahrtschein zu nutzen ukraine
komplett einzumarschieren
also das eine ist dass das weiße haus
natürlich sagt man konnte nicht
weitergehen weil die ukraine ist nicht
nato territorium das heißt solange putin
irgendetwas in der ukraine macht kann
man nur mit sanktionen und definitiv
nicht mit militärischen aktionen darauf
antworten das hat der amerikanische
präsident immer sehr klar gemacht aber
er wird gedrängt und zwar allen voran
von beiden parteien im amerikanischen
kongress auch von seiner eigenen viel
weiter zu gehen er hätte so sagen die
republikaner eigentlich diese sanktionen
schon vor wochen zwar hängen sollen da
denken einige aber im weißen haus das
wäre schädlich gewesen dann wäre es noch
schneller eskaliert weil putin sich
nicht hätte abschrecken lassen also
fordern abgeordnete beider parteien
mittlerweile dass er das gesamte
sanktionspaket verhängt was noch viel
weiter gehen da wäre es würde
beispielsweise alle technischen güter
betreffen die nach russland geliefert
werden allen voran die güter in denen in
irgendeiner form amerikanische
technologie wie software oder mikrochips
vorhanden ist das würde die russische
wirtschaft aber auch das
verteidigungssystem russlands sehr hart
treffen so weit ist der präsident heute
noch nicht gegangen er hat diese
einzelnen weiteren maßnahmen auch gegen
den energiesektor russlands nicht
aufgeführt ganz offenbar in der hoffnung
dass man zunächst einmal abwarten muss
was wladimir putin in den nächsten tagen
macht aber in dem moment wo er seine
truppen über diese ganz engen von
separatisten gehaltenen gebiete hinaus
in den rest der ukraine hin war hinein
entsendet das wäre der moment wo noch
viel schärfere sanktionen so sagte der
us-präsident folgen werden
vielen vielen dank für diese ganz ganz
ganz ganz frischen informationen von
beiden räder vielen dank für die
einschätzungen eben auch von der aus
washington vielen dank es gibt eine
antwort die emma gegeben hat auf eine
frage die aber an sie gerichtete sana
uhr ari schreibt über facebook wie
findet der experte also sie general
ramms die reaktion des westens ich finde
den westen zu lasch und zu langsam in
der reaktion elmer hat jetzt gerade ein
bisschen dargestellt warum und wieso
beiden sagt in verschiedenen schritten
und maßnahmen aber wie ist denn ihre
einschätzung
ähnlich wie die fragestellerin gerade
gesagt hat ich habe eine ähnliche
auffassung ich war gestern abend bei der
berichterstattung
unter anderem aus dem bereich der eu
über den über den beauftragten für die
eu-außenpolitik wo etwas entsetzt als
der sagt jetzt müssen wir uns mal
hinsetzen und müssen über sanktionen
nachdenken daher je nach donnerwetter
jetzt immer schon sechs wochen acht
wochen in dieser situation
es ist uns immer gesagt worden in der
zwischenzeit wir bereiten das alles vor
das wird alles koordiniert das wird
alles abgesprochen und in dem augenblick
wo es losgeht sagt man jetzt müssen wir
das mal klären uns zusammensetzen
koordinieren und dergleichen dinge mehr
da hatten wir gestern abend der
amerikanische präsident deutlich besser
gefallen der relativ schnell die ersten
sanktionen gegen die beiden separatisten
gebiete verhängt hat von daher war das
eine prompte reaktion die gleiche
prompte reaktion werde ich mir von der
europäische union oder auch von
europäischen staaten erwartet ich muss
den briten ein bisschen abbitte tun die
sind ja nicht mehr der europäischen
union aber die briten haben heute
reagiert und haben wollte auch die
ersten sanktionen verhängt von daher
rasch und langsam licht nicht neben dem
thema hier kommt noch mal zurück auf die
rede des russischen präsidenten gestern
denn die hat auch ein anderes kapitel
gehabt es ging nicht nur darum um die
anerkennung der selbsternannten
volksrepublik darum das militär
reingeschickt wird zur hilfe sondern
putin erklärte auch er sieht die ukraine
als teil russlands sondern hat tief in
die geschichtsbücher gegriffen in seiner
geschichtsbücher und erzählt warum er
das so sieht er sieht den heutigen start
nur als konstrukt und über diesen teil
seiner rede was putin da geschichtlich
analysiert hat behauptet hat wollen wir
mit einem experten reden mit dr andreas
umlandt politikwissenschaftler publizist
und osteuropa experte gründer auch der
buchreihe sowjet and post sowjet politik
society insofern der richtige mann zu
fragen wie putin das ganze denn gemeint
hat erstmal schön guten abend und vielen
dank dass mit dabei sind
spontan die frage was ist ihnen denn
durch den kopf gegangen als sie putin
gestern gehört haben
ja dass man im grunde solche geschichten
über die zufälligkeit von staaten von
grenzen von völkern jahr über die
meisten völker erzielt erzählen könnte
gestern hat schon der kenianische
vertreter im uno-sicherheitsrat meine
ich sehr gut darauf geantwortet dass
eben auch sein land kenia eine ehemalige
kolonie ist die zu verschiedenen
imperien mal
gehört hat und in gewisser hinsicht
zufällig zustande gekommen ist das geld
in gewisser hinsicht auch für die
ukraine und das gilt eben in gewisser
hinsicht für viele länder der erde
insbesondere für ehemalige kolonien die
ukraine war zunächst im touristischen
imperium dann im sowjetreich quasi eine
kolonie und das was putin da erzählt hat
ja das könnten das könnte man über viele
länder erzählen die eben nicht selbst
imperien gewesen sind
das war eigentlich das was ich damals
dann wollen wir ganz konkret darum land
einfach mal reinhören ihn eben einen der
entscheidenden sätze auf denen sie jetzt
auch abspielen vielleicht haben aber
einige eben ja die rede nicht komplett
verfolgt das hat putin eben gesagt
die moderne rizzoli ist voll und ganz
von russland erschaffen worden genauer
gesagt vom bolschewistischen
kommunistischen russland
dieser prozess kann praktisch nach der
revolution von 1917
lenin und seine mitstreiter machten das
auf einer für russland sehr grobe weise
[Musik]
durch abtrennung eines teils seines
eigenen historischen territoriums
millionen menschen die dort gewohnt
haben wurde nicht gefragt
was will damit sagen hat er recht hat es
da nie eine ukraine gegeben und ist sie
sozusagen von den russen
zurechtgebastelt worden oder hat es
nicht einen unabhängigen staat gegeben
also wie ich das schon angedeutet habe
das gilt natürlich für kolonien häufig
dass die dann von den imperialen
nationen von imperial zentren geschaffen
wurden und dann aus diesen kolonie neben
staaten entstanden sind natürlich gibt
es eine
kulturnation viel länger man könnte die
unterschiede zwischen den großen und den
ukrainern so in etwa vergleichen mit den
unterschied zwischen den deutschen und
den niederländern es gibt also
ähnlichkeiten in der geschichte und in
der kultur und auch in der sprache aber
es gibt eben auch bedeutende
unterschiede es gibt eine ganz eigene
ukrainische literatur kunst philosophie
wissenschaft musik und so weiter und die
ist halt weniger bekannt als die
russische weniger gut verkauft weil eben
die ukraine teil dieses von russland
oder aus moskau dominierten imperiums
des zunächst des touristischen dann des
sowjetischen war aber das ist natürlich
einfach eine spielerei die putin da mit
den fakten macht zumal dieser herr lenin
der angeblich die
geschaffen hat dessen leiche liegt heute
immer noch auf dem zentralen platz in
moskau und in gewisser hinsicht stimmt
das natürlich dass die grenzen der
heutigen ukraine eben die grenzen der
ehemaligen chemischen sowjetrepublik
sind aber darauf haben sich eben
russland
belarus und die ukraine beim
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion im
dezember 1991 geeinigt dass man diese
grenzen anerkennt übrigens gibt es
karten der ukraine als kulturnation die
weit in das heutige territorium der
russischen föderation hineinreichen das
cuba an gebiet nördlich des kaukasus war
einmal auch weitgehend eine sprachlich
gehört heute zu russland und man könnte
jetzt sozusagen aus ukrainischer
position sagen ja wenn wir schon hier
die die grenzen neu definieren warum
warum sollte dann das kuban gebiet also
das heute zu russland gehört nicht
wieder nicht in die ukraine
also das sind alles zu spielereien die
wenn man ein bisschen die weltgeschichte
kennt sehr schnell durchschauen kann
weil man ähnlich geschichten natürlich
über viele grenzen und viele länder
erzielen können kein general ramms nicht
stimmt ihnen zu ich habe im grunde
genommen an sie beide so ein bisschen
die frage was bedeutet das ganze wenn
die verbindungen ja auch so eng sind
kann man sagen putin kann sich
eigentlich keinen krieg mit der gesamten
ukraine leisten weil es eben doch viele
verbindungen gibt weil es vielleicht
viele russen gibt jedoch verwandte haben
in der ukraine weil die geschichte doch
miteinander so verbunden ist und das
insofern bei der heimischen bevölkerung
schlecht ankommt oder zieht dieses
argument in sachen anfangs strichen heim
ins reich also was er sagt die ukraine
zurückholen ins russische reich kommt
dass beim volk an wie ist das
einzuschätzen doch sowohl im historiker
die ford ja sicher
naja ich meine so wie wir uns
wahrscheinlich auch darüber freuen dass
wir jetzt nach österreich und in die
schweiz und den niederlanden reisen
können ohne probleme weil wir eben jetzt
alle die deutschen und diese diese
länder zur europäischen union gehören
insofern sind wir werden vielleicht auch
die ukraine und auch die russen
glücklich sozusagen miteinander
verbunden zu werden aber darum geht es
ja hier gar nichts geht ja um vor macht
und unterdrückung um um eben die
absprache einer eigenen identität und
das ist natürlich
einfach ein realistisches gehabe und
deswegen wundert mich auch sehr dass es
immer noch in deutschland unter anderem
viele linke gibt die dieses dies den
imperialismus
dieses
koloniale verstellt verständnis der
ukraine mit verständnis sozusagen
betroffen wir haben es nicht also mit
blick auf die mit blick auf die
fragestellungen aufgrund der rede von
putin würde ich gerne noch anmerken das
ist ja letztlich eine frage ist wo ich
denn bitte schön die schnitt linie
ansätze wann das ukraine oder wann das
russland war oder was zusammengehört und
dergleichen mehr putin hat sich auf die
moderne beschränkt also mehr oder
weniger sage ich mal ende 1920
jahrhundert bis heute wenn man die
grenze 1000 jahre weiter zurück liegt
dann gab es den sogenannten klima fonds
weit vor dem moskauer nämlich etwa rund
400 jahre dann könnte man sagen wer war
denn zuerst da erster aussage zweiter
aussage ich pflichtete bern professor
bei dass
die ukrainische sprache die ukrainische
kultur auch noch in anderen bereichen
die weiter ostwärts und weiter nördlich
liegen eine relativ große rolle gespielt
hat die aber zum teil durch die politik
von stalin der ja diese verschiedenen
bevölkerung die dort waren auch in
russland ausgetauscht hat absichtlich
ausradiert worden sind schlicht und
einfach auf diese art und weise
formuliert zu den zweiten teil mit der
ukraine möchte ich eine anmerkung machen
was die ukrainische um die russische
bevölkerung angeht also wir haben ein
ganz klares gefälle von west nach ost
was den ukrainischen anteil an geht also
die ukraine die in der ukraine leben und
ein großer anteil lebt als russen in der
ukraine im östlichen teil der ukraine
das erklärt auch die situation mit
transgourmet ton jetzt wobei auch da
wieder vorsichtig anzuwenden ist da
reden wir so um die 50 52 prozent russen
und 48% ukrainer wobei sich diese
prozentzahl in den letzten jahren etwas
verändert haben zugunsten der russen
einfach aus dem grunde weil ukraine aus
diesem bereich geflüchtet sind jetzt
kommt aber die spannende frage eben
genau wenn sich diese aufteilung und
diese verteilung sozusagen in der
ukraine vom westen aus ansprechen
andreas super so der der user super
schreibe über youtube frage an andreas
umlandt aber wir sind ja auch gerade
dabei wohnen viele russen in der ost
ukraine sie sagen ja beziehungsweise
russischsprachige menschen und wie sehen
diese menschen denn die separatistischen
bewegungen herr doktor umland
das ist gespalten
man muss allerdings
betonen dass dieser krieg der entstanden
ist im frühjahr 2014 von russischen
staatsbürgern begonnen wurde es gibt
inzwischen forschung dazu dass also
solche abenteurer wie georgien oder
alexander barta 3 diesen krieg begonnen
haben und das waren keine regulären
russischen soldaten die standen aber
auch dass es inzwischen erforscht in
direktem kontakt mit dem russischen
staat das waren agenten des russischen
staates irreguläre agenten des
russischen staates keine offiziellen
angestellten dieser korrigieren war ein
ehemaliger fsb offizier ein veteran
föderale sicherheitsdienst ist
russlands der übrigens unter unter putin
als putin direktor des fsb gewesen ist
gedient hat und der hat dort eine
entscheidende rolle gespielt und wer war
in engem kontakt mit der russischen
führung und als dann dieser krieg
ausgebrochen ist dann mussten sich die
russen vor ort entscheiden sozusagen auf
welcher seite sie sie sind viele haben
sich dann natürlich sagen instinktiv für
die russische seite entschieden andere
haben sich für die ukrainische seite
entschieden es gab dann viele
freiwilligen bataillone auf der
ukrainischen seite in den russisch die
verkehrssprache war die also weitgehend
aus große sprechern bestanden und eben
auch viele ethnische russen
eingeschlossen haben diese ganze teilung
großen nicht russen ukrainer nicht
ukraine dass das funktioniert nicht also
das entscheidende ist hier die rolle des
russischen staates sowohl bei der aktion
der krim als auch bei der auslösung
dieses krieges 2014 und erst dann der
krieg begann begonnen hat dann war es
nur noch schwer sozusagen nicht mehr
partei zu ergreifen dann mussten sich
die russen entscheiden und ich sagte
jetzt hat natürlich sehr gut sind
natürlich viele auch geiseln quasi
dieses krieges geworden an der spitze
des russischen staates steht eben
vladimir putin und kommen wir noch mal
zu seiner rede denn hier haben wir auch
noch einen ausschnitt wo es um die
geschichte aus den auch durch die augen
putins geht
die ukraine hatte nie eine tradition der
staatlichkeit von 1990 an haben sie
mechanisch einfach fremde modelle
kopiert
politische und staatliche institutionen
sind ständig verändert worden
die entscheidung das land pro westlich
auszurichten dient nicht dazu bessere
bedingungen für das volk zu erschaffen
wie ist das denn zu interpretieren so
lange also eine pro russische
ukrainische präsident an der macht war
ist alles okay sobald ukraine nach
westen schaut gefällt dass putin nicht
mehr darum land
nur für diese invasion
2014 markt wobei man hier betonen muss
dass
janukowitsch geflohen ist als der
aufstand bereits zu ende war und zu dem
zeitpunkt als janukowitsch geflogen ist
gab es keine
todesfälle mehr es gab auch danach keine
todesfälle mehr und viele der
gefolgsleute janukowitsch sind ja in
kiew geblieben den ist denen ist nichts
passiert und janukowitsch ist dann etwa
achtet worden vom römischen parlament
nicht von den revolutionären des euro
weiter an sondern vom dänischen
parlament das ihnen bis kurz vorher
unterstützt hatte und während in eben
diesen russischen der aktiv sozusagen
die die das bild geliefert wird das
angeblich diese prowestlichen
revolutionäre den gerne kobe den arm
janukowitsch vertrieben hätten und
entmachtet hätten das stimmt so gar
nicht ja also diese diese geschichte mit
dass es da keine staatlichkeit gegeben
hat das kann man in gewisser hinsicht so
sagen wie das eben für kolonien
ehemaliger imperien generell gilt dass
die eben keine staatlichkeit hatten und
dann eben die grenzen auch die die
können ja die imperialen mächte
gezeichnet haben wie das schon gesagt
habe übernehmen und heute als staaten
existieren vielen dank darum haben wir
das eingeordnet und general ramms ich
möchte noch eine anmerkung dazu machen
zu diesem geschichtsthemen
die ukraine hat mal als land existiert
aber nur ein halbes jahr und das war am
ende des ersten weltkrieges ganz konkret
vom 29 april 1918 bis zum
ersten november 1918 also wenn sie so
wollen vor dem ende des ersten
weltkrieges das hat was mit der
revolution 1917 zu tun das hat was mit
der situation in russland damals mit der
aufteilung in weißrussen und rote armee
oder rote russen zu tun und in dem
bereich wo die ukraine waren damals
hauptsächlich auch über die kosaken
dergleichen mehr weißrussen und in
dieser zeit hat es für ein halbes jahr
einen eigenständigen staat gegeben bevor
dann dieser mit hilfe der roten armee
durch die sowjetunion die später
gegründet wurde es aber bewusst sagt
kassiert worden ist
das sind auch alles so interessante
dinge von denen man aber in der rede von
herrn putin nichts gehört hat es ist in
der tat bedauerlich dass wir herrn putin
nicht dazu holen können um gemeinsam mit
ihnen diese geschichtlichen fakten zu
klären und eben seine interpretation in
frage zu stellen und was watching über
youtube schreibt werden interessante
frage die an herrn raum stellt die
könnte man auch putin stellen deshalb
wird zwischen der ukraine und russland
eigentlich keine demilitarisierte zone
eingerichtet zumindest temporär ich
glaube da kriegen wir heute keine
antwort nimmt also zumindest hat man ja
dieses bei den beiden abkommen minsk 1
und minsk zwei versucht indem man
versucht hat die linien festzulegen die
beiden seiten zu separieren voneinander
das sollte ja auch nicht ein
sicherheitskorridor sein und man muss
aber eindeutig feststellen da wieder ein
vorteil für die separees noch für die
für die eu für die ukraine dieses
waffenstillstandsabkommen insbesondere
minsk wo es von beiden seiten verletzt
wurden und das ist glaube ich müßig da
komme ich noch auf einen anderen punkt
dabei jetzt nachzuvollziehen wer ist
derjenige gewesen der ist verletzt hat
wobei wir eigentlich in der europäischen
union ein falsch in europa über die osze
dazu eine möglichkeit hätten denn auch
russland auch die ukraine wir und viele
andere europäische staaten 35 stück
insgesamt sind osze vertragsstaaten und
wir haben für solche fälle entsprechende
kontrolle entsprechende osze-beobachter
und solche dinge vorgesehen nur wenn die
keinen zugang zu dem separatisten gebiet
bekommen ist die kunst von denen und der
stelle auf zu ende
ganz zum schluss möchte ich sehe an
beide mit bitte um ganz ganz kurze
antwort die frage noch weiter reichen
die partie über youtube schreibt welche
konsequenzen hat das ganze was wir jetzt
mit der rede jetzt erleben für andere
postsowjetischen staaten muss jetzt
sozusagen gezittert werden nachdem was
wir jetzt in den letzten 24 stunden
erlebte anfang wir bei ihnen einfach mal
an herr doktor umland
ja sicherlich da schauen auch die
anderen länder drauf ich würde hier aber
eher in die geschichte zurückgehen und
kritisch anmerken dass ermutigen ja im
grunde nur das macht was er vorher schon
zb mit georgien gemacht hat und
in die orgien sind ja nicht wie in der
ukraine 7 prozent des territoriums de
facto besetzt von russland sondern 20
prozent des territoriums von russland
wir haben damals nicht darauf reagiert
wir haben im gegenteil 2008 als das
passiert ist eine
modernisierungspartnerschaft mit
russland begonnen und das war eben dann
eine lehre für guti und auch wie die
anderen länder im postsowjetischen raum
dass das man nicht auf den westen nicht
zählen kann und in gewisser hinsicht
wundern sich jetzt wahrscheinlich die
leute in moskau einfach auf einmal
länder wie deutschland so so entschieden
reagieren auf das was da in der ukraine
passiert während das was vorher in der
republik moldau oder in georgien
passiert ist ohne jegliche sanktionen
verblieben ist dort hat sich russland im
grunde selbst sehr ähnlich schon lange
vorher von kurze antwort von ihnen war
schon das nicken er ganz ganz kurze
antwort von mir ich war ein august
september des jahres
2008 in den baltischen staaten im rahmen
einer militärischen aufgabe die ich bei
der nato wahrgenommen habe als
vorgesetzte militärischen nato
vorgesetzter das war kurz nach dem
georgien-krieg und bei den baltischen
staaten egal ob in estland lettland oder
litauen konnten sie zu dem zeitpunkt die
angst anfassen konnten sie anfassen und
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass das in
den baltischen staaten zur zeit wieder
genauso aussieht
danke ich ihnen ganz herzlich
general ramms und auch sie doktor umland
vielen vielen dank es hat gezeigt dass
es sich lohnt intensiver und
detaillierter sich die rede von putin
anzuschauen zu schauen was ist wirklich
dran was sind seine interpretationen und
ich danke ihnen ganz ganz ganz herzlich
dass wir uns die zeit genommen haben
denn der blick eben auf die details auch
in die geschichte eben hat gezeigt wenn
man viele mosaiksteine zusammensetzt
kann man eben das eine mosaikstein was
wir heute in den letzten 24 stunden
erleben vielleicht besser verstehen
insofern vielen vielen dank dass sie
dazu beigetragen haben die dinge
vielleicht dazu verstehen vielen dank
auch für ihre fragen die dazu
beigetragen haben einen schönen abend
doch tus und auf wiedersehen